a company's logo often represents the
mission and values of the brand but more
than often it holds some secrets that
most will never get to learn about stay
tuned until the end to find out what the
McDonald's golden arches really mean
make sure you like this video and
subscribe to our Channel today we're
checking out 10 famous logos with hidden
messages Coca Cola if you love Coca Cola
you're going to love this story the Coca
Cola Company first finalized the formula
behind their famous drink back in 1886
and began creating the famous Coca Cola
logo which went through several
rebranding styles before settling with
the logo you know today but the Coca
Cola logo has an unintentional hidden
message which was pointed out by the
happiest country in the world the
company had no idea they're giving a
shout out to the entire country of
Denmark you can find the hidden message
between the letters O and L the letters
along with the red and white colors
perfectly represent the Danish flag
Denmark of course took advantage of this
unintentional shout-out as it's the
happiest country in the world people in
Denmark greet you with a small flag at
the airport when you arrive when the
company noticed a hidden message in
their logo they decided to put the flags
on the coke poster isn't that one of the
most creative welcome messages ever and
it's not the first time coca-cola and
Denmark worked together to deliver
secret messages this coca-cola ad can
only be read by colorblind people
however unlike the secret message in the
logo this ad was completely intentional
tastes the happiness was Coca Cola's
tagline in 2009 and we're very happy
that the company also spreads happiness
even when they don't know it Nike the
story behind the Nike logo is quite an
interesting one after seeing the logo
for the first time the chairman of Nike
said that he didn't like it but it will
grow on him the team behind Nike's logo
didn't know it will become one of the
most recognized logos ever well that's
because it wasn't a team that worked on
the logo it was designed by a graphic
design student named Carolyn Davidson
back in 1971 and she got paid just $35
for it the logo is called swoosh and it
resembles a curved check mark but
there's a little bit more to it than
just a simple line the logo actually
represents an arc of movement and
symbolizes motion and speed it's the
movement of basketball players flying in
the air and hitting that slam dunk it's
the movement of a runner a dancer and
any other powerful athlete did you know
that the name Nike actually comes from
Greek mythology Nike was the winged
goddess of victory and the modern
version of Nike brings victory to the
athletes that wear the brand so next
time you see the Nike logo you'll know
that it represents a bit more than just
a check mark and don't worry Carolyn
Davidson did end up getting a share of
Nike and was properly compensated for
her hard work later on my fonts if
you're a graphic designer
you've probably used my fonts website
more than once the company which is
originally based in Massachusetts is
known as the number one database of
fonts that are available to download or
to purchase from talented designers it's
a fantastic way to showcase your
calligraphy skills as a designer or to
expand your graphic design portfolio by
trying out different font styles the
site has been around since 1999 and it's
still one of the most popular font
resources out there unlike companies
like coca-cola and Nike my fonts logo
isn't that recognizable but that doesn't
mean that it doesn't have a hidden
meaning pay close attention to the word
my have you noticed that the letters M
and y actually look like a hand the logo
is basically telling its users that they
can get their hands on all sorts of
fonts on their website the design also
plays with the actual action of
calligraphy as designers use their hands
to make these fonts anyways
what a totally brilliant idea for a logo
but that's not it we think that the
letters have an extra meaning when you
turn it upside down it suddenly turns
into a cute little dinosaur do you see
it even though dinosaurs really have no
relation to my fonts and the company
probably didn't think about this we love
to find hidden meanings in our favorite
logos mercedes-benz let's talk about
cars mercedes-benz first appeared on the
scene in 1926 the company is known for
focusing on innovation and pushing the
boundaries of design and technology of
transportation the company soon became
one of the best known and most reputable
car dealerships out there and their logo
is one of the most recognizable on the
market while many car companies change
their logo at least once mercedes-benz
has always stuck with either the three
pointed star or the circle as their logo
so what's the actual meaning of this
three pointed star
many companies make sure their mission
is clear in their logo and mercedes-benz
does
exactly that the three-prong star
represents the connection between the
land sea and air it's a symbol of the
company's drive toward universal
motorisation with their products and
their mission to produce unstoppable
engines anywhere in the world basically
they want to dominate the world and they
suddenly show that in their logo we're
pretty sure that the circle represents
the earth but we have no doubt that it
will disappear once they create vehicles
that will fly us off into space there's
an endless debate over which car brand
is the best but you have to admit that
mercedes-benz is one of the most popular
car makers out there Northwest Airlines
we've already talked about several
interesting companies with clever
stories behind their logos but we bet
you never noticed the hidden message in
the simple logo by Northwest Airlines
Northwest was founded in 1926 and due to
the airline's constant mishaps with
their customers and employees the
company became a target for many
Canadians but you can't deny that
Northwest is a pioneer when it comes to
the development of aircraft technology
North West's logo went through several
changes but have you ever noticed a
hidden message in this logo do you see
it look to the left can you see the
letter n take a closer look at the
letter and the triangle there's a hidden
letter W but that's not all the circle
and the little triangle also represent a
compass the triangle actually points to
North West although it might seem like a
very simple logo compared to some of the
other ones on our list Northwest
Airlines really knows how to pack a
hidden message in their brand did you
know that the first Northwest flight
took off in 1927 without a radio or any
security technology you know today
sounds scary doesn't it check out one of
their first logos they really came a
long way since then so next time you're
on a Northwest flight pay attention to
their logo and see if you can spot the
hidden message Museum of London we love
creative logos and this next one is no
different if you ever travel to London
there's a good chance you'll go to the
Museum of London to learn more about
this city's fascinating history its
historical stories are definitely worthy
of learning and the museum will take you
on an amazing adventure back in time
this is the logo of the Museum of London
see those colored shapes they're
actually not completely randomly
designed they represent just how much
London grew over time in size it all
starts with that small circle that
represents the city of
Londyn which is now its own district
overall London currently has 326
districts and it's still expanding every
year the Museum of London's logo was
actually designed by an award-winning
designer who did a really good job at
highlighting the city's growth in
population and diversity over the years
the logo also reflects the ever-changing
diverse and dynamic makeup of London and
its community from past to the future so
if you do come to London make sure you
visit some places that are outside of
that tiny dot that represents the City
of London experience the hidden message
behind the logo in real life and see the
diversity and unique culture of the city
well done Museum of London this logo is
really clever
howdy speaking of interesting logos have
you ever wondered what's up without E's
logo
well Marcy's Benzes logo shows off the
company's mission which is world
dominance OD story is a little bit
different
howdy has to be one of the most
recognized logos out there and one of
the most beloved car manufacturers in
the world Audis history dates back to
the 19th century did you know that the
company was established back in 1899 it
was one of the biggest car manufacturers
in Germany and it's vehicle soon became
known all around the world but let's pay
attention to Audi's logo do you know
what the four connected rings represent
the four sealing rings actually
symbolize the four oldest German car
manufacturers these four companies out
he included were the foundation on which
the modern outtie AG is founded Howdy's
logo barely changed through the years
although the company did come under fire
over the resemblance to the Olympic
rings the world Olympic Committee
actually took out e to court over the
similarities but they ended up losing
the case it wouldn't be the first time
out he would come on the wrong side of
the Olympic Games but the company always
managed to come out as winners
maybe it's the four magical rings that
are bringing them good luck 80/20 80/20
S logo might not mean anything unless
you're a mathematician and if you are
you probably figured out the meaning of
this logo in a second but don't worry if
you're not because we'll break it down
for you
80/20 is a consulting company from South
Africa and even though they're not known
worldwide their logo makes them stand
out from the rest and we want you to
know about it we'll try to explain it in
the simplest way possible do you see the
blue and grey squares there's actually
more meaning to them than you might
think they represent a binary sequence
the blue squares are number one and the
gray squares are zero each horizontal
line represents a different binary
sequence but that binary sequence also
has a different meaning the first line
represents the number 80 and the second
20 and together
it's 8020 the company uses the power of
research and analytics to help clients
deliver customer centric strategies and
it definitely proved that with their
clever logo challenge your friend and
show them the 80/20 logo and see if they
can figure it out remember the blue
squares represent the number one and the
gray ones are zero Apple you've probably
heard the joke that it was Windows that
bit out of the Apple from the company's
logo well Apple fans have a lot more
theories about the meaning of the logo
the Apple logo is actually connected to
Alan Turing who pioneered research into
artificial intelligence and laid the
foundations for the modern-day laptop
technology Alan wasn't recognized for
his work and ended his life by biting
into a poison apple and this is where
the bitten Apple comes into play this
story seemed to be true for the longest
time but it looks like some Apple
employees believed it was a myth some
also say that the Apple represents
knowledge from the story of Adam and Eve
and many think it's related to Sir Isaac
Newton's concept of gravity the designer
of the logo said that the Apple
represents a symbol of lust knowledge
hope and anarchy this means that the
initial connection to Alan Turing is
completely false so what is the secret
message behind the Apple logo it's a
mystery
whether it's a symbol for knowledge or a
tribute Apple sure knows how to keep
their customers in suspense they're so
mysterious they don't even have a clear
meaning behind their logo they just keep
you guessing what do you think the Apple
logo means McDonald's let's talk about
McDonald's one of the most popular
fast-food franchises with one of the
most recognizable logos ever some even
say that the logo is more recognized
than the actual cross everyone knows the
yellow and logo but do you know it's
hidden secrets stay tuned they're pretty
amazing the logo of the franchise
actually changed quite a bit over the
years the golden arches are just as
famous as Walt Disney's logo or even
Apple so what do they actually mean the
arches were actually designed to
resemble the female chest the idea was
introduced by a psychologist who came on
board to create the logo he wanted to
add a subliminal meaning
the M and according to him the customers
experience a freudian importance in
their subconscious it's not clear
whether the company actually ever
confirmed this hidden message but the
Internet is pretty fascinated with the
new meaning behind the logo speaking of
McDonald's did you know that the company
sells 75 hamburgers every second they're
also one of the largest toy distributors
in the world so next time you're in a
McDonald's think about the subliminal
meaning behind the company's logo does
the Freudian Theory work on you or you
just in it for the food don't forget to
hit that like button and subscribe to
our channel for more videos like this
one check out 10 biggest logo fails of
all time thanks for watching
[Music]